Мене звати Михайло Мені 14 років Я
навчаюсь у середній школі Я люблю
математику та грати в різні ігри зі
своїми друзями я
аутист
подарунок до вас
є таких дітей як Михайло в Україні
десятки тисяч і вони потребують нашої
підтримки і прийняття А ще якісних
освітніх і корекційних послуг тому що
кожна дитина з аутизмом має право на
щасливе повноцінне життя дитина з
аутизмом - це перш за все Дитина Вона
просто має свої особливості ми
Закликаємо вас підтримати дітей дощо у
соціальних мережах поширивши фотографію
у блакитному одязі або елементами одягу
використав хштег Кожен особливий Не
будьте байдужими Кожен особливий Кожен
особливий